[Music]
gentlemen I want to start by saying how
much I enjoyed the first two episodes of
the show thought they were fantastic
thank you for people that don't know one
watching is gonna know your guys's name
so can you each say your names and also
what you actually you know you did on
the show my name is Alexander Wu
I am the co-creator of the show and I
was the showrunner on the terror infamy
my name is Max Borenstein with Alex I'm
the co-creator of the show an executive
producer okay so I want to go backwards
the first season of the terror so well
done I really enjoyed it
where's the genesis of the second season
is it when the first season is on you're
pitching ideas or is it like when did
this whole thing germinate that's
started with max well I I was in before
this before the first season of the
terror came out I was sitting down with
some of the executives at AMC and they
were telling me about it and they showed
me a kind of sneak peek of what it was
and I was a bit familiar with the book
and was so impressed by what it was but
they said they were looking for a new
iteration of the show that would be
another season in an anthology format so
something that wouldn't necessarily draw
directly on the story that came before
but maybe create a franchise by building
out another story that was based in a
moment of real history with a genre
component and and that's all they said
but they said they were really bullish
on wanting to do it so do you have any
ideas about history and I'm a huge
history buff so it was a fun little game
to think about and I didn't know if I
would have any ideas but I went home and
I was looking through my bookshelf just
kind of like that old that history books
wondering like gee I wonder if you could
what would be an interesting moment in
time to explore through this genre lens
and one of the books on my shelf was
George Takei's autobiography and I had
met him when I first bought a copy and
and and he was giving a seminar about
his experience in the japanese-american
internment camps and I was so that was
just one book I looked at and then it
was the craziest thing where I woke up
at 3:30 4:00 in the morning and it was
like wait is that an idea and I grabbed
my phone
the thing you do where you're like that
usually turns out to be like you know
monkey paw
you know dragon and you're like I don't
know what the hell that means but
actually when I woke up again and at a
more reasonable hour was coherent and
felt like a really cool idea which was
what if we were able to explore that
totally underrepresented and and
tragically kind of brushed under the rug
moment in American history and do it
with through the lens of a genre show
and and so that was the initial impetus
and then you know Alex took it and ran
with it and made it into something
magnificent really I came up with an
idea for a board game once in my sleep
in the middle of the night I woke up I
woke myself up laughing because it was
so ridiculous it's not worth getting
into now but I did but that's the best
idea I best idea I had so how long when
was that that determination how many was
shortly before the first season that
actually what was the year was it
2017-18 out of a year and a half ago
eighteen so this thing happened really
fast
it sure did yeah that's what I'm trying
to get it cuz things don't usually
sometimes the action you know it's funny
I remember very well like it was uh it
was about uh yeah the very beginning of
2018 and then at the very beginning of
2019 you started you started shooting
like almost a year to the day when I had
had an initial meeting with them I was
on set and they were shooting the pilot
I mean with the first episode so it was
kind of it did sort of uh I then went
and made a movie that I had written
twelve years ago so it's like that's
there's the wide range yeah things
should happen sometimes super super fast
and that was the tech challenge
that was set before us where we want to
be on the air in the summer of 2019 okay
a few Ulster's later one of the things
as I was watching it I noted I think it
was in the first episode where I noticed
there on a dock they're walking no
sudden I saw something in the background
I'm like did I just see that and that's
a rewind the the episode and be like oh
I did see that um I don't want to spoil
anything for people that are watching
but
often are things going on in the
background like that that you're like
what we have a few Easter eggs it was a
nod to the the Japanese horror movies
that we love which are sort of descended
from the Qaeda and ghost stories so you
know we're starting with the Kobayashi's
quite on and then like the dark water
rain grudge type type movies and one of
those classic toys in the toolbox is
toys in the sandbox to mix a metaphor is
is just sort of plant something there
and not focus the camera on it it's just
there and if you get it it's really
creepy if you don't you miss it you miss
it but if you do see it it's this really
sort of creepy feeling like you're
you're in on a secret that is that is
really scary that they don't know about
and and we have a few of those
throughout the throughout the course of
the season yeah I thought that was great
I love when stuff like that's going on
in the background so you have ten
episodes how on a show like this do you
end up with a lot of stuff on the
cutting room floor or is it sort of like
at the end it means literally everything
you shot ends up in the thing when we
started when we we didn't realize first
of all I mean we were given a very
aggressive schedule because we had to be
on the air in this in the summer of 2019
but we didn't realize the pace that the
show naturally had and this is one of
the difficulties of writing a good part
of the season before you get into
production that the natural pace of the
show is very methodically slow but it's
not one where you zoom it's not gilmore
curl so you know you're not blazing
through a whole bunch of dialogue and so
the initial episode one which was
something on the order of 48 pages ended
up being I confess 82 minutes of screen
time way too much and eventually cut it
down then it fits in like jumbo-sized
a little over an hour now this explains
why the first episode is longer yeah
it's a little bit longer but it could
have been a lot longer yeah
it could have been 82 minutes so but we
also knew from that point that point on
we couldn't afford to shoot a whole
bunch of stuff that we wouldn't end up
using so the scripts got shorter and
shorter as you know as we started
delivering episode seven eight nine and
ten they were like 32 33 34 page scripts
and we used all of it but there's so
much there's so much suspense and
tension and the direction and
cinematography go and the production
design goes such a long way to building
this mood in the show and that's a big
part of what what's really I think kind
of exceptional about it and and it's the
kind of thing that requires like time
it's dispensed rather than surprise
right there's a little punctuation this
but really you're at the edge of your
seat and it's the kind of thing that
might not take very many pages to write
but it but when it feel it on screen
when when it works what you're saying
it's fantastic and it works in these
first two episodes but if it doesn't
work it is a boring song well you know
what it is it's funny because it's like
I think it's a high wire act and it's
risky and we live in a moment where
people have become increasingly afraid
of that like more and more movies you
know I become from the future world and
it's like there's a pressure constantly
to like have a lot happen real fast and
when you watch the movies we grew up
loving if you watch Star Wars the new
hope or something you realize man this
is a slow movie compared to what's made
now I get deliberate it's it takes its
time you learn you meet these characters
and like it takes 30 minutes for
something really big to happen after a
little pop up front and it's like I
think you know but when you hit that
like the way jaws does the way star was
like there's some magnificent stuff you
can do and I think it's exciting that
AMC's like you know gave Alex the
freedom to really tell the story in the
right way and not sort of like try to
you know goose the audience in a fake
way but really build the tension but I
also think that's one of the reasons why
so many people love Star Wars and so
many people love jaws and one of the
failures are some movies today is that
you'd listen like with the terror with
your show I carried about the characters
because you have character stuff and
when you have those moments of scare
like you know what I mean but like those
older movies you give a [ __ ] about the
people on screen and the problem today
with these movies
with some of the blockbusters I've seen
recently is that you know you have eight
minutes of screen time of character
development and so when things start
happening to them you don't care
it's just explosions development becomes
you just have to go to the quick cliches
to make it make sense but this is a show
that like it's that the characters are
so specific and their backgrounds so
specific and I think you know there's a
real richness in the way that the the
episodes have been written and then
performed that I think to the to your
point it makes the horror that much more
powerful because you're really invested
and there's two there's two aspects to
the medium of television that I think
we've taken advantage of here one is
that it takes place over an extended
time period so it's not one emotional
experience like the movie would be it
takes place over in our case ten weeks
so you can spend those seven intervening
days between episodes worrying about
these characters and if we've done our
job you care about them you've lived in
their skin so you're pissed off at them
or you're happy for them or you're
fearing for their safety whatever it is
but you care and you're invested and you
one know what's gonna become of them
from week to week to week the other
thing that television does and game
thrones aside is that it is increasingly
a more and more intimate and less
spectacle driven medium because you're
watching it less and less on a
television set it gets closer and close
to your face and you're watching it you
know I I watch a lot of television on a
tablet six inches from my face in my bed
you know with what the lights turned out
so you can take advantage of something
that kind of worms its way into your
brain a little more than you would with
something you know on an enormous screen
where it's you and 300 other people and
you know you're there to get your socks
blown off but I will say that one thing
I've lose every time I would watch the
dailies for this and see what you guys
were able to pull off
production-wise like it's spectacular
looking like it really like the thing
that's amazing about the show I think is
that it's you know it really transports
you to in a world at a moment that's
been like we've seen things about world
that era but we've never seen this story
and it it it it really goes on an epic
kind of journey that from considering
it's a television show it's kind of an
amazing and we will we will accept none
of the credit we don't deserve any of
the credit for that is
our cinematographers John Conroy and
Barry Dunleavy and our production
designer John's McKinstry our costume
designers Tish Monahan Jo Baker made a
made a world come alive that is sort of
in my dreams it would be you know you
know like one of those shows where you
see just a frame it like madmen or
Sopranos you see a frame oven you know
what it is and I feel like amazingly
that happens on the terror no I I think
whatever the hell I just said you know I
thought your production design and all
the the technical stuff behind the
scenes it just looks you like you've
been transported and again that adds to
why you get the [ __ ] do you know and I
mean it all looks believable I had a
million other things but I'm already
being given the hook so um I'm just
gonna stop there and say I can't wait to
finish the show and so far it's great
thank you so thank you so much